mitgefühls hoch fragt mein erstes mal
sechs fragezeichen
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
wir spielen heute wieder eine runde jump
league nach langer langer zeit mal
wieder
ich weiß das aber hat mich gewarnt aber
hey wir wollen keinen groll gegen gegen
den server
wir verzeichnen noch mal dafür dass uns
gewandt hat europa unter youtube.de ohne
scheiß leute ich saß heute da und als
youtube ist es manchmal nicht leicht man
sitzen so da denkt sich so scheiße was
zur hölle lade ich wollte eigentlich
hoch man jetzt komplett ratlos überhaupt
kein plan was man machen soll und
deswegen dass sie auch so da dachte mir
okay leben mich komplett vorbei grad
und dann fiel mir aber ein dass man noch
etwas machen könnte was ich bisher so
noch nicht gesehen hat jeder kennt das
format und kann ich im mittelalter und
das problem im juni ist zumindest aus
meiner sicht dass die frage wieder
oftmals gestellt werden hier so ein
bisschen so dass jetzt keine besonders
spannenden fragen zum offen halter zu
fragen wie jahr bringt vermehrt raus
oder wie kamen dann youtube name
zustande
eigentlich immer nur diese beiden fragen
so in jedem einzelnen keeway ja du dich
wehrt sich hätten oder so aber die
pannen kommt vielleicht auch deswegen
dass wir mal okay wie kann man das
machen dass man das trio wissen mehr
aufpäppeln und deswegen machen wir heute
einen tuner mit ausschließlich extrem
fragen ich hab euch wieder gebeten
hatten wir nur extreme fragen zu stellen
für dich gewinnen und ich würde sagen es
kann auf jeden fall einige extreme
fragen rein
damit legen wir jetzt einfach mal los
gaming hd fragt übrigens sehr sehr guter
junge sich immer auf twitter was ist das
peinlichste erlebnis was jemals passiert
das kann ich erwähnen alles klar okay
für gaming danke danke bei dem gut und
leute das peinliches erlebnis da fällt
mir direkt was ein und zwar schon bevor
es im day ist in der achten klasse
es war was in der achten klasse legt ab
29 presse aber immer dazu müsst ihr
wissen dass ich ein bisschen früher mit
der schule angefangen habe ich war acht
in der 5 dann war ich in der 19 12 12
bis 13 alles klar also die vs 12 bis 13
hat mit musik überhaupt nichts am gut
also ja ich höre ab und zu musik aber
damals habe ich größtenteils eingepreist
gehört also nicht so der deutschen musik
geschmack aber ich habe vor allen dingen
nichts mit tanzen am hut und dann waren
wir eine skifreizeit in österreich da
hatten wir so ein vereinshaus so eine
größere hütte da haben alle gewohnt und
diese hütte hatte eben auch so ein
ausgelagertes zentrum wo man sich
treffen konnte zwar ein separates haus
es war so was wie sympathischen
spieleabend wie man erkennt dann haben
uns dann getroffen mit allen klassen die
damit in der freizeit waren
und dann kam irgendein depp und ich
hasse ihn bis heute für diese idee auf
die idee einfach ein fucking dance
battle vor allen zu machen also das
müsste ich wirklich vorstellen ein
fucking dance battle ich war zwölf leute
ich habe noch nie in meinem leben
getanzt bis dahin und ich hatte so
riesig schiss davor und das dance battle
war am ende schüler gegen lehrer und ja
dann geht's los dann sagen sie so ok
haben wir alle genug spaß gehabt jetzt
irgendjemand leiden so und haben sie
damit machen dance battle und ich dachte
schon so ach du scheiße bitte nicht ich
bitte nicht ich bin ich ich und dann
gehen sie so rum und sehen so aus
welchen schüler nehmen wir denn der
gingen lehrer an
sebastian und nicht so oh mein gott ich
werde sterben ohne wirtsleute jetzt ohne
witz ist so das herz in die hose
gerutscht unwahrscheinlich mir ist so
krass herzlose cello ich hätte den
adrenalinrausch meines lebens allein
davon dass sie mir gesagt mach dich kurz
fort dreieck ganzen klassen blamieren
und ja leute dann hat es mich in dem
moment wirklich erwischt und ich war ich
war wirklich schockiert so kann man wie
gesagt okay wir im schüler gegen lehrer
dritte annahmen zu irgend ein lehrer
ausgewählt und ich war schon total
geisterwesen leute ich war innerlich
schon gestorben zu dem zeitpunkt ich war
zu dem zeitpunkt einfach innerlich schon
tot also ich weiß ja wie das kind in ein
licht gegen tot sei wahrscheinlich kennt
es nicht und es ist besser so leute und
dann ging es los ich musste aufstehen
musste nach vorne gehen und das war eine
riesige halle leute versteht mich nicht
falsch das war eine riesige halle und
drei ganze klassen die alle mit auf dem
schiff weiter waren saßen in sitzreihen
vor mir
das war und ich war so unfassbar nervös
und dann stellt sich auch mit der lehrer
vor mich auch vor allen leuten und dann
fangen die einen auf einer musik zu
spielen und es liefert waren das habe
ich werde ich niemals vergessen welches
lied er lief zwar culcha candela hey dj
bring den team zurück leute mit dem weg
könnte mich jagen jedes mal wenn ich das
hier bekomme ich ein flashback und dann
weiß ich ja gar nicht was passiert dass
ich das leider lief einfach ein film ab
ich habe mich super ort bewegt ich
wusste überhaupt nicht was ich machen
sollte und alle leute haben
ich weiß nicht ob die leute gelacht
haben aber sind zumindest innerlich
gelacht haben sie wahrscheinlich mit mir
mit geschehen das war so traurig aber ja
das war glaube ich so mit der
peinlichste moment seines lebens leute
und ich gehe noch weiter alter die sie
diese nagel am modul diese nächte
knackig man okay er mit drei blöcken
müssen wir hier so daraus nicken und
dann ab und zwar hier in blau war das
kloster fehle jetzt hier runter junge
diese neue module sind echt nicht ohne
vor allem wie lange die sind leider
mercy und es war nicht mal halb modul
das war medien module leiter partie ist
wieder am start mit dem ultra hat
modulen die als medien module verkauft
werden
im vergleich dazu ist das window play
module hat hier so easy also keine
ahnung und eisen diamant super aber ja
machen weiter mit der nächsten frage
hast du jemals für etwas abhängig drogen
handy ich weiß nicht was ich jemals von
drogen abhängig zumindest nicht von
nicht von illegalen drogen also nach dem
motto des studiums oder vor oder
komplett
wie soll ich keine partie mehr wie sie
kriegt keinen
ich krieg gar nix alter mann die von
drogen abhängig aber ich glaube ich war
sehr lange vom computerspielen abhängig
habe ich gefühlt also ich hatte echt
eine phase lang da war ich so in der
neunten klasse der schule jetzt nicht so
besonders beliebt was heißt nicht
besonders beliebt aber in der schule
habe ich gehasst und ich hatte nicht so
wirklich viele freunde und hat auch
keine hobbys und deswegen bestand mein
tag ungelogen einfach daraus nach hause
zu kommen und dann einfach so gestresst
zu sein von der schule dass man erst mal
das bedürfnis hat alles wieder zu
vergessen und alles zu verdrängen und
dann habe ich nicht einfach so es ging
locker mehrere monate lang einfach jedes
mal nach der schule hingesetzt und habe
fünf stunden computer gespielt oder so
und ich habe mich danach nicht mehr so
gut gefühlt ehrlich gesagt ich hab mich
die ganze abgefuckt gefühlt aber ich das
war ich dachte mir dass das einzige was
ich machen kann und aber jetzt kommen
zwei und jetzt bin ich tot ja also ich
war auf jeden fall war
computerspielsüchtig und läutet meine
mutter ist dabei auch er sowas von
ausgerastet so meine mutter hat mich so
behandelt welche nicht nicht eventuell
computersüchtig sondern so einfach echt
heroinsüchtig finden so also ist voll
ausgelastet immer wenn ich pc gespielt
habe deshalb mittlerweile auch in den
griff bekomme ich zocke nicht mehr so
viel dafür machen videos live des
tisches
peinlichstes erlebnis mit einem mädchen
gut also ich würde sagen auf jeden fall
eines der peinlichsten erlebnisse war
für alle die das von außen gesehen haben
was bestimmt nicht peinlich 5 für mich
was im moment so peinlich und zwar war
es meine erste freundin die hab ich halt
in der pause immer getroffen der
schulpause und dann hat man sich ja
immer so ein kleinen kurs gegeben einmal
hat sie einfach so folgten die busbucht
gegessen und der kostet so unfassbar
scheiße geschmeckt ich bin auf mein
leben nicht mehr klar gekommen
er war so ein fakt ist er verfolge
gegessen es ist ein lächerlicher welt
darüber redet und die kanal kopf
versucht von außen nicht zu zeigen dass
ich innerlich einfach gerade verände
aufgrund dieses geschmack ist das war
jetzt mal mein erster gedanke ehrlich
gesagt und ich glaube das war wie von
einer peinlichen momente mit mädels
wahlleute von auslandsmärkten aber
innerlich so richtig bei mir dauert
der leser bekommt gelitten haben feuer
ja da kommt der angel spam du kleiner
club nichts gegen gezielt eingesetzt
alle zusagen aber sowieso viele leute
die einfach so richtig krass so richtig
krass krass und brad ist aber auch schon
gefressen
also wenn einfach so die leute seht ihr
so richtig absetzen
dieser versuchte 20.000 pro sekunde
eines bremer wisst ihr schon okay der
leidet jetzt gerade neu gewonnen das
ging schnell eine frage mit reinnehmen
mitgefühls hoch fragt ein erstes mal
sechs fragezeichen
es ist auf jeden fall nicht so groß wie
name anschrift telefonnummer und e mail
adresse von der person geben mit der
s-bahn gegangen ist ja wenn ihr das
wollt dann schreibt man die kommentare
ja es war keine ahnung gar nicht so
wirklich der rede wert
man munkelt auch gewisse involvierte
personen werden zu dem zeitpunkt nicht
ganz nüchtern gewesen aber darum
letztlich darauf einige leute das was im
heutigen video endlich gefallen hat dann
lasst auf jeden fall ein ei da okay
bitte euch lassen
und wir sind zunächst video wieder haut
rein macht's gut und